and what did he give me? You knelt down I think I
was nervous So I don't
remember all the details either but you
knelt down I think and then since he's on his
knees looking for something in his pocket
I thought you why is he
doing that I can't believe it, it's not that  He's going
to give me a ring, it's here
rauw Alejandro and Rosalía and we're here
asking the
first question which is the
karaoke song my go to karaoke song
[Music]
the one I always want to sing
also
gasoline
of course
What tangible things I have of yours and what
they are my favorites
for trips it is true yes because you
wear a lot of perfume So it is
inevitable they always smell a lot
next question what is my
hidden talent is it hidden you cannot say
one that only you know It is that what
happens is that it has been many  things that did not
come to my mind can be said understand
when you cook you do not burn the oil you do not
burn anything you put your hand in the
pan at the door nothing happens to you
Where and when we had our first
kiss Madrid
December 2019 Christmas Eve before Christmas Eve
the number and everything eh What is the first
thing I eat when I wake up Well if
we talk about breakfast some toasted
cookies I don't know what kind of cookie it is but
it's like corn wheat with avocado Yes
and turkey ham and olive oil and salt
Yes exactly  What instrument would I like to
learn to play? What do you need
to play the flute? I
swore that you knew how to play all the
instruments,
baby. I have always told you that I want
to play the drums
[Music]
What are the three things that I
always take with me when I go out?  from home
three things that you always carry with you
avocado mayonnaise and a ginger no no
avocado you can check your bag
right now
and you always go with your
calendar book a calendar book your
calendar is true on which side of the bed
do I sleep on the right side then  sometimes
I sleep on that side for a while on the
other she moves more in bed I am
more I fall asleep there that can be
interpreted in another way
than What sign am I Libra very good What was she
wearing when we met she
had a black suit
some peculiarity of the suit had
piercings in the nipples and in the navel
that's why it couldn't be seen Yes clear as a
diamond I didn't look that way so much so
as not to be so so Crazy the first
date of course and what did I drink And what did you drink
our first date I drank  whiskey and you
drank water
drink separately me with a drink I get
fine I with a drink I'm already here for
the drag What is my favorite type of milk
milk with sugar But
when I learned to drive motorcycles and who
taught me I think it was at 13  years old
and his mother ride motorcycles and who taught me
your father dear father-in-law
greetings to father-in-law If I could live
anywhere in the world where would it be
Sure you would live in Japan you would live
in
Greece Holy State
especially
Barcelona come approved Who is my
greatest flamenco musical inspiration
You have a huge list there, a
musical inspiration, you always talk,
I really like it,
which is my favorite place in Barcelona
to eat, go out, dance with whatever,
baby, that you have already changed with me there,
come on, I don't remember the name and to
dance, but one of  They were one of us
that I remember
the name but the Apollo
of the university is dogged well Because
in music University of music but my
career was a kind
of interpretation of flamenco singing it's worth
very well very well very well what I do
before I sleep What is it  my sphincter
routine the milk cream in the
crazy cream cleaner with the with the
wet towel
serum there is one step missing there
the exfoliation
serum and the eye cream here and with that it is
hard for her to sleep
it's true that's where it goes
What is my bra size
well,
what is the best way to make me laugh?
It is true one specific thing that makes
me die laughing I
tell you not as I have as we
have a door and then you
appease me
when he pushed your bed when you are going to
go to bed later
in a prison it is also true  also
where we last met eh where we
met for the first time and what was my
impression of you the company focus on fell in
love at first sight
[Music]
we met in Las Vegas at the Latin
Grammys
what a gift you have given me on my
favorite
motorcycle  that I gave you that is it is there from
my fans But there is one that is more special
one very very
special very special very very special you
gave me in Puerto Rico I gave it to you
in Puerto Rico Oh I don't know
a little box the box
the box with all the  photos of us
made me a
customer box of a lot of photos and vibes
of us and in that box that is
big there well I keep all the
things that are called I keep it
on the motorcycle
What is my ritual or what do I do before
getting on  a stage you
hang out with the buddies eat Doritos
have a laugh but always Then you have
a moment in which you pray you say
a prayer that same good I have written
many songs for you Which is the deepest that I
have written for you as a museum
[Laughter]
this boy
obviously
What I wanted to do when I was a footballer child
What is my favorite sweet or sugar
and tres leches dessert I do
n't know if I told you but where
my next tattoo will be on my body you
haven't told me I haven't told you but I
can guess
on the leg on the back the
next tattoo I think it's like
how different Saturn wanted to
do something about my mom she loves the
Panther I wanted to do a flamenco dancer
like several things I like Yes right now
I tell you Good da  a ticket to
travel to where I would tell you to go a
place on vacation a place we
have already been
a part of the world some part of the
world right now you always want to
be in Puerto Rico but you also
love Japan
and Japan that I studied at the
science university and after physiotherapy you
almost left me stiff
that was what you studied and then
and well that is what I was going to finish what you
were going to finish was
business
finance finance
but that already but that already
today you are very  business, that
is, me because of my finances, I am much
more terrible, on the other hand, you are very
good at
music, what was my position as a
footballer on the field, I thought that
striker striker because ice cream
[Laughter]
favorite Cristiano Ronaldo Ok I'm going to
say it here  since we are here on
YouTube how we got engaged and who
proposed to whom we got
engaged exclusively in the
most beautiful way that I could have imagined
could exist because it was the house in
your grandmother's house in a part of the
most part of  all the way up the
building And then they started to see
fireworks you could see all of Puerto
Rico canóvanas you could see all of Puerto Rico
from up there and I didn't expect it
and you told me come I want to show you a
place I want to take you a place I
want to take you a  I want to
show you a place and I followed you thinking in the most
innocent way Ah come on let's go and all of a sudden you
started looking for something and I thought what's
wrong with him and how come you didn't get it out
like that he's
looking and
you knelt down I think if you're nervous
Then I don't mind either  I agree with all the
details but you knelt I think and
then as I was surrounded looking for
something in my pocket I thought
why are you doing that to him I can't
believe it, it's not that he's going to give me a
ring So you gave me one
and then  I started to cry
and that's how we got engaged How do
you know when I'm upset Your
face looks like this for miles and also because you say
bastard
and who of the things that bother me the most
in your work is important to you
anyway  very clear
with you that things are very very
transparent so when they are not
100% transparent I think that bothers you I
hate the lines I also hate waiting
once we stood in line in Paris for
an hour for a restaurant I did it for
love a proof of  love That was a
proof of love what is my favorite place
in Puerto Rico Carolina
What is my favorite Puerto
Rican food rice with jamonilla cutlets
tostones rice with beans
What is my favorite animal the monkeys the
monkeys
I have seen you that you have sent me
videos of little monkeys that
were my favorite animal that I have always
told you that
a horse a horse the horses
little monkeys
how I want my retirement to be without having to
do anything
like I tell you what I want to do with myself
in the city or country in the countryside
big family
and  and a good time
What are my favorite artists
Michael Jackson
Bruno Mars
come on I'm going to make you one more than if not
I'm from the horoscope I always have
a dyslexia from the horoscope because I
think that you are a capricorn
No I think that you are a Sagittarius But
you are  capricorn very well no yes you
know me quite clearly congratulations baby
on your dots
congratulations baby on your dots
[Music]